>> SCHWARTZ: Okay, welcome. Thanks everybody
for coming today. This morning at the key
note, we introduced Google Storage for Developers,
and today we'd like to tell you a little bit
more about it. Hi, my name is Mike Schwartz.
I'm an engineer working on the Google Storage
project. And my colleague is David Erb; he
is the engineering lead for the project. And
together we're going to talk to you about
Google storage. And if anybody has questions
or do you want to see notes about things,
as we're presenting, please copy down this
link and visit us on wave. We'll just wait
a couple more seconds to let people have a
chance to copy that down. Okay, so Google
Storage is a Cloud-based binary objects store,
and by that way mean that things are structured
as buckets and objects. So a bucket is basically
just a flat name space. You can get a bunch
of buckets and you can put objects in the
buckets. And for those of you who are familiar
with other Clouds storage provider, this is
a pretty common paradigm. You see then, Microsoft
2.0 and Amazon S3. And the key thing to think--take
away from this is you can have many, many
buckets. Buckets can have many, many objects
and objects can be really big. And we'll talk
a little bit more about some of those sizes
later. Another aspect of Google storage is
that you control your data, and this means
a couple of things. First of all, you can
make data private. It's only visible to you.
You can make it shared and you can--we'll
talk more about the sharing model. It's pretty
flexible sharing model that we'll be introducing.
You can share it with individuals and we'll
talk more about groups too. And you can also
make it public. So the entire world can see
your objects. You have a choice over that.
And the other aspect about you controlling
your data is that you can get your data out
in anytime. And we believe this is important,
across Google, we believe it's important.
It's your data. You should be able to get
it all out completely, anytime you want to.
Finally, what is "for developers" mean, the
products called Google Storage for Developers?
Well anybody will be able to sign up for this
service. We're introducing it as a trial,
as a preliminary version for now and we're
going to give you guys a chance to get invites
for this initial period a little later in
the talk. But, eventually, everybody would
be able to sign up, but the product is really
aimed to developers. So this means a few things.
First of all, it uses a RESTful API; and for
people who haven't heard the term, REST stands
for Representational State Transfer. It's
essentially the model that HTTP is based on.
You have a limited set of verbs, like PUT
and GET and then you have URIs for naming
everything in the system and so all the operations
are modeled as simple verbs with URIs. And
Dave will talk more about that later too.
Also there is many different software development
kits and tools. Lots of open source tools
and software development kits, many that prig
us the project and also some one's that we're
introducing, we'll talk about those. And also
there's good integration with Google services.
So what are some of the benefits? Well, first
of all, it's built on Google's high performance
and scalable infrastructure. So we'll talk
more about replication and how we get performance
and availability out of the system later;
also, very flexible authentication and sharing
models, which again we'll talk about later.
And it's easy to get started quickly with
third party tools and utilities. Some that
we provide, some--like I said before that
are available in the open source world. So
first thing I'd like to share you is a quick
demo. It's very easy to get start using Google
Storage and like I said at the end of the
talk, we're going to give you a link where
you can ask to be--to be given an invite.
You'll click that invite and you very quickly
can get into using Google Storage, and I'll
show you what that looks like right now. So
you'll get an email in you box, after you
fill out this free form to ask for an invitation.
And when you click on the email, it says thank
you and here's your invite. If you click on
that, here's the invite, and as you'll notice,
I'm actually using a little temporary account
here for the rest of the demos we do. I'm
not going to use this account. I'm using this
temporary account so that it's actually a
brand new invite. This account has never used
Google Storage before. And when I log in,
what you is some terms of service, a little
welcome page. Some terms of service that you
should read and you click it--click accept--accept,
and the first thing you're taken to is some
documentation. And you're welcome to cruise
the documentation, there's a lot of information
available here. However, it's pretty easy
to get started in. If you want, you don't
even need to go to the documentation and you
just can go right over this link Google Storage
Manager and show you this. So the Google Storage
Manager is a web-based user interface that
we're providing as part of this release. It
has a simple explorer like model that you're
familiar with from also different explorer
services. And as you can see, right now I
just have kind of an empty account, no buckets.
So the first thing I'm going to do is create
myself a bucket. And I'll give it an imaginative
name, mynewbucket, creates the bucket and
you can click down into there. There's nothing
in there, right now. It says the thing is
empty and you can drag objects in there. So
for example, I'm going to drag this image
that I have on my desktop. It's uploading
this and this is--and then what I can do--you
can see over here, there's a checkbox, it's
created out right now. That means that the
object is currently private. So the default,
if you don't specify anything else or when
you first upload the object, this is private
and you can later change the ACLs. If I click
on this checkbox, I have now just made it
publicly readable and there's more flexibility
than that, it's not really exposed right here.
We'll talk more about ACLs later. But you
could at this point if you want it. Go copy
this link and email it to your friend or post
it on a blog. Or have you want to expose the
thing, what I'm going to do instead, I'm just
going to click on it, download it again and
here's this object that I just loaded. This
is actually a picture of some of the folks
who worked on the project, up in the Seattle
office. Okay, so it's as easy as that, you
get an email, you click on it, you read some
terms of service, and immediately you can
start using Google Storage. And just then
when I did that, you know, data was copied
down to all of our services and replicated.
How--David is going to talk later more. It's
quite easy to use. Okay, so let me talk briefly
now about some of the services inside of Google
that use Google storage. There's a number
of one's up here, and if you look at them,
the way I like to break it down, is the first
two: Panoramio and picnik. These are services
that are a lot like some services that view
as a developer might build. And by that I
mean basically lets your users upload data
and share with other users as--then can come
in and get to the data. So it's a pretty common
usage pattern. The ones over here on the right
side, double click and YouTube; these are
modeling, if you will, services that are different
kind of service that you might build which
is services that generate data and then other
services consume that data. In this case,
I'm talking about reporting data. And that
is all done through big store. I mean through
Google Storage. The--the next one, the Data
Liberation is basically uses Google Storage
as a platform for letting users gets all of
their data out of various use, Google services
and google.org. So, a few months back when
the earthquake hit Haiti, there was a need
for the people who were delivering relief
to get access to multiple terabytes of satellite
imagery and so we used Google Storage to give
them a way to get at that data. And then on
the bottom here, Google BigQuery and the Prediction
API, these are a couple of great new services
APIs that we just announced at the conference
this morning. These are analytic frameworks
that let you work with really large data sets.
And I encourage you to go to tomorrow's 10:15
AM talk to find out more. But let me just
give you a kind of the brief, briefest, you
know, one liner for that. Basically, Google
BigQuery lets you analyze what happened in
the past, so understand the past. And Google's
Prediction API helps you to predict the future
based on enormous data sets. We also have
a number of current users that are partners
who helped us, you know, test out and give
us feedback and worked with us, as we were
bringing the product to market. You can see
a number of their logos here and we're going
to actually show you a couple of demos today.
I want to show you simplicity and the U.S.
Navy, today, right in this talk. So at this
point I'd like to turn things over to Damon
Moritz, who's with the U.S. Navy Office of
the Information to give a demo.
>> MORITZ: Hello. I'm the video manager for
the U.S. Navy Office of the Information in
Washington, D.C. And our office mission is
to collect and disseminates still photos and
video that comes to us from throughout the
fleet. And we hand those videos off to the
media, documentary producers, we upload it
to YouTube, places like that to help tell
the Navy story. Now, when I started this job
seven years ago, it's kind of difficult. We
would receive a file. They'd give an FTP to
us, whatever. A good example is the tsunamis.
So the files would come in, we would ingest
that file, burn it on a tape, run the tapes
down to the media, come back upstairs, delete
the media because there's a new file. It didn't
work. So we went looking for good solution
to allow us to do one good piece of work and
then profit from that work forever. In fact,
we're still profiting from a lot of the work
that we did early on and then doing that we
found MediaBeacon. So MediaBeacon got us going.
We were doing pretty well. We have a single
Ethernet line that fed it on a 100 Meg pipe
coming into the Pentagon. Things were good,
things were real good. We did Haiti--I'm sorry--we
did Katrina, we did any piracy operations.
But then came Haiti; one of the biggest events
that we've ever dealt with. And we went from
doing a peak of about 20 terabytes of data
burst to 85 terabytes in a span of a month.
And everybody kind of panicked, our customers
are calling saying, it's not fast enough,
it's not giving us what we expect. So we said,
"Well, we have the truck. We know how to package
it up and get it in our truck and now we need
the highway. We need to get it out and get
it out faster." So we started looking around
and what we came across luckily was Google
Storage. And Google Storage has done some
pretty neat things for us and--actually, I
forgot to start this. This is going to be
an example of what MediaBeacon looks like.
It should play. Anyway, so what MediaBeacon
with Google Web Toolkit and HTML5 did for
us in the--yes, it's coming--with Google Storage
it has given us a way not only to deliver
to our customers, and they don't notice any
difference, except that they get better bandwidth.
For us it's a huge deal, it's a massive deal.
We don't have any complaints at all. Here
we go. What is done beyond that? Is it's given
us a much better way to receive files. So
the 286 ships that the Navy has at sea, actually
half of them were at sea today, some of them
were trying to send us files and we have shore
stations all around the world, they're trying
to send us files. And that has--it has and
will greatly improve our ability to receive
files so that we can be much, much faster
in receiving, delivering our content to the
media. So, again, for us it's a huge deal.
Thank you. Thank you.
>> ERB: Thanks very much. So as Mike said
in the beginning, I'm David Erb. I'm the engineering
lead for the Google Storage project up in
Seattle. And I'm really excited finally to
be able to talk about it and to tell you what
we've been up to. Google Storage was conceived
as a platform for highly available, highly
secure, high performance data storage and
transfer. When we set about trying to design
the system, one of the first things we did
was to try to think about--well, you know,
what should this API look like? What should
the--what should the paradigm be for our storage?
And we--we adopted the philosophy that said;
we want to work with what customers are finding
successful today. So we designed Google Storage
to work well with a lot of existing tools
and libraries. And one of the paradigms we've
picked up, as Mike mentioned, is this idea
of buckets and objects. So what are buckets?
Buckets are flat containers, they don't contain
other buckets. They form a global name space.
So if you have a bucket of a given name, no
body else in the world can have a bucket of
the same name. That can lead to some confusion,
of course. So one of the things that we introduced
is the idea of that if you control a DNS name,
you can use that as the basis for a name space
of your own. You have to verify that you control
the name space but you can then--if you're
in food.com, you can then have buckets that
are called things like images.food.com and
text.food.com and whatever. And just keep
creating them to you heart's content. Another
thing that we heard from customers was that
it's very important, of course, not to lose
their data and to make it available all the
time. So one of the things that we do in Google
Storage is on every right, we replicate the
data to multiple locations, multiple geographic
locations, currently only in the U.S. And
despite the fact that we're doing that, we
provide a strong consistency model and I'll
talk a little bit more about that later. Another
thing that we thought was really important
was to make it simple to authenticate requests,
to prove that the requestors who they--they
are. And we have a couple of ways of doing
that that I'll talk about in a minute. We,
also thought it was important to have flexible
ways to share content. To say, securely, I
want so and so to be able to read this but
not the rest of the world. And then, finally,
in addition to all the--the tools and libraries
that are all ready out there that we thought
it was important to work with, we thought
it was important to provide some tools that
help you get started quickly. Mike all ready
showed you the Storage Manager and he'll be
showing you a command line tool a little bit
later. So Mike all ready mentioned the RESTful
API, here all the verbs and the API. You can
use the GET verb to list the contents of a
bucket or to retrieve a natural object, the
PUT verb to create a bucket or to create a
new object. You can use POST to build forms
that your users can use to securely upload
content to your Google Storage bucket. HEAD,
DELETE, pretty obvious. When you upload an
object, you can specify the object type, the
content type and we'll just serve it as that
type when it's served up. And objects can
be practically any size, hundreds of gigabytes.
As I'll mention in a minute, there is--during
this preview period that were beginning today,
there is a 100 Gigabyte per account limit.
So that is effectively a limit on object size
for the time being. And another thing that
we did as far as the sharing model was we
wanted to make it possible for you to share
securely, but in a simple way. So we took
advantage of Google accounts. Many of you
users have or can easily sign up for a Google
account associated with your email address
and you can share content to a specific email
account. In the very near future, we'll add
support for sharing to groups. And that's
important because suppose that you have an
object or collection of objects, let's say
a large collection of objects, maybe a billion
objects that you shared with some long list
of people. Well, that list might change, as
people come into your company and--or leave
or, you know, whatever your business needs
are. That group might change. You don't want
to have to go update a billion objects. Instead,
you can just go to the groups.google.com and
manage the membership of your group to manage
access to your objects. I also mentioned that
we wanted to support flexible ways to authenticate
requests. And so when you share something
to someone with a Google account, they can
access that content, just be on a normal web
browser, as long as they're logged in to the
Google account. We also support signing requests.
When you sign up, you get a key pair. You
get a public key and a secret key. In this
request, you can see a few of the common elements.
So PUT the verb, then the--the name after
PUT, specifies a bucket. I creatively named
it mybucket and then the rest of that is the
object name. The slashes don't matter, it
doesn't matter what characters you put in
the object name. So my/long/objects/name is
all one object name. And then host, our URL,
commondatastorage.google.apis.com, bunch of
other, more or less self explanatory fields.
And then the authorization header, Google1
identifies this as a request that uses this
syntax native to our service, because we want
to work well with other tools and libraries
that already exist. That might also say for
example AWS and which case we would interpret
it not as Amazon credentials but as a request
formatted in the Amazon web service format.
That's followed by a public key that begins
with Goog and bunch of numbers and then a
signature that you compute using a secure
hash over the contents of the header. When
you create an object--I didn't specify any
access control in that previous request, and
so by default it was private. I can read it,
nobody else can. I could've specified that
it was public or I could've specified a few
different simple things that you can--you're
supposed to find the header or I could upload
an access control list later and determine
who has what access to the object? The access
control model is pretty simple, access control
list supply to buckets and to objects. In
the context of a bucket, an access control
list to determine who can list the contents
to the bucket, read information, determines
who can create new objects in the bucket,
write permission, and then full control means
people can interact with the bucket ACL as
well. The object to ACL model is even simpler.
You can either read the object or you can
have full control over its ACL. You'll notice
there's no right ACL on an object and that's
because the right permissions are associated
with the bucket. And that does mean that if
you have right access to a bucket, you can
overwrite or delete objects that are in that
bucket. So I'd like to show you a quick demonstration
of one of our partners did around our sharing
model.
>> CHUNG: Hi, I'm Leonard Chung, CEO of Syncplicity.
Syncplicity is a file management solution
that lets you easily sync, share, access and
back up all of your files across all of your
computers and Google docs. We'll also provide
a way for IT to essentially control and protect
files across the company through policies
and recording. We all ready provide first
class synchronization of any files Google
Apps and Google Docs, with nearly 12,000 customers.
We think this market is going to find Google
Storage to be a compelling solution. Let me
show you Syncplicity integrated with Google's
Storage. I'm going to modify a document on
my desktop as it normally would within my
My Documents folder. I double-click on the
file and it opens right up in Word, only a
few changes to the document. Now, go ahead
and hit save, just as I normally would. As
I hit save, in the background, Syncplicity
has automatically backed-up version synced
and if I so desire share this file in real
time. If I'm part of a company, it automatically
also complies with my corporate information
policies including retention and sharing as
set by my company administrator and can be
set to be pushed to existing infrastructure
like file servers. If I switch over to my
laptop, you'll be able to see that the file
have automatically been changed and synchronized
down to this computer. If I'm on my mobile
phone or at any computer, I can access the
new version immediately through either rich
client or an optimized website. And if I refresh
the document listing in my Google Docs account,
I'll be able to see it here as well. If the
change was accidental, I could restore the
original file myself through the Syncplicity
website instead of calling IT. But I can also
call my IT administrator to do the restore
remotely. I'm not going to touch on the full
administrative capabilities of Syncplicity.
What to demonstrate, I'll switch over to my
web browser while I'm logged in as an administrator
and do remote restore of the previous version.
All of this is possible in real time, because
of the robust and formant consistency model
in Google Storage. We're excited that Google
is innovating at their storage layer with
[INDISTINCT] to Google Apps and other Google
infrastructure. We can leverage this rich
functionality to deliver more capabilities
and a terrific user experience to our customers.
As you can see, the previous version has immediately
flowed back down to my desktop. We manage
over 250 million customer files today, spending
hundreds of terabytes. Our mutual customers
have been asking us for a syncplicity solution
that included Google Storage. So we're pleased
to be here today.
>> ERB: One of the things you might have noted
in that brief video was a mention of how some
things are possible due to the strong consistency
model. Let me talk a little bit more about
what that model is and what it might mean
to you? When you write an object to a Cloud
storage system, you want to--you want to make
sure that you'll be able to read it after
you've written it. It's kind of obvious, it
goes without saying. But one thing in our
experience with Google that has really been
driven home to me is that you have to be prepared
for things to fail. Disks fail, computers
fail, racks of machines failed, data centers
failed, the networks fail, whole regions can
be out of commission and you have to keep
things working in the face of all these kinds
of failures. So in particular when you write
something, you may--the write may work and
everything might--might go very well and the
system that you write to might generate a
success response and that response might never
get to you. You might have gone off-line,
the network may go down, anything could happen.
So you
need to understand the behavior of this system
and the presence of that--of that kind of
behavior. So our model is very simple, if
you do it right and you see it succeed, all
subsequent reads are going to see the results
to that write. If you do it write, you can't
tell what happened; if you do a read, and
you see the results of that write. All subsequent
reads will see the results of that write.
So what does this mean to you when you're
building your applications? Well, I built
this very sophisticated web form here, in
my application and I'm using it to serve this
form to a customer, so they can upload a photo
to my service. So the user clicked submit
and does he--then it'll be post to Google
Storage or whatever Cloud storage provider.
In that--the FORM post there's a redirect
that tells the browser where it should go
after doing the--after getting a success on
the post. And the--so the redirect sends the
browser back to your web service, to my web
service. Or say, my server that--that's running
the--the photo App. And that's how I know,
it's how my server knows, my App knows that
that user has submitted some new content.
So what I'm going to do? Of course I'm going
to go immediately read the content. I'm going
to index or I'm going to thumbnail or I'm
going to do something else with it. But I
might have a totally different region. I might
have a server on the other side of the country.
With a weak consistency model or an eventual
consistency model, that might not work. You
might get a 404 back. But with the Google
Storage consistency model, you know that the
success of the previous write means that you
will be able to read the content. In this
case, delightful family photograph I took
on a hike near Seattle. Let me talk a little
bit also about Interoperability. It's our
strong belief at Google that it's important
for you to be able to have a choice. For you
to be able to choose the Cloud provider that
you want to work with and for you to be able
to choose the tools that you want to work
with. So this drove a lot of our decisions
about how to build Google Storage. You should
be able to move your data to choose a Cloud
provider or even multiple providers if that
make sense for you. And you should be able
to use a consistent toolset with those providers.
So with that, I'm going to turn things back
over to my colleague, Mike, who will show
you some examples of how Interoperability
works.
>> SCHWARTZ: Okay, so what you see here is
a diagram of some of the tools I want to talk
about here. As I've mentioned earlier, there's
quite a few tools, open source tools and libraries
available, I'm talking about just a few of
them here today. Earlier, I gave a demonstration
using GS Manager, a web-based tool for interacting
with Google Storage. Today, I'm going to--right
now, I'm going to show you an example of using
command line tool that were open-sourcing
and releasing with the product today called
GSUtil. And GSUtil is implemented on top of
the popular boto open-source library which
is a Python library built for interacting
with Cloud storage services that was implemented
by Mitch Garnaat. And I'm also going to talk
about the App Engine SDK and show you how
easy it is to build an application that uses
App Engine to top to Google Storage and serve
it off of the Google App Engine infrastructure.
So here I've got a simple show command line
prompt and GSUtil was fashioned after simple
Unix command for listing and copying data
around. And so, for example, if you just say
GSUtil LS, this shows you all the bucket set
I--this logged in user has, log in I should
say, this user whose credentials are known
by the GSUtil tool. So in this case, I just
have the one bucket and you'll see that the
command line tool produces listings with the
URI-like syntax and so here it's saying this
is GS provider with the bucket GS2010. And
you actually can name providers, buckets,
and objects this way. So, for example, I could
use the same command and I could list this
command "gsutil ls gs://" is equivalent to
the little shorthand I just did. I could also
use it to list--this user happens to have
buckets at Amazon S3 service and I can even
do it--I can even list both. So, on the single
line I can list all the buckets that I have
in both of these services. The next thing
I want to show you is how to put your upload,
your data to the cloud using this command
line tools. So I'm going to just use a local
Unix "ls-l" command. You can see I have in
this directory a couple of files and a directory.
And so I want to upload all this data to the
cloud and I can do that simply by saying "gsutil
cp *" and I'm going to copy it up to this
bucket that I already show you I have and
that's--it's as easy as that. It's going to
copy all the files and all the files within
on the bucket and all the directories up to
the cloud. And I can see that the files had
been copied there now by doing an LS on the
bucket. Okay, so those are the files. I can
also use an "ls-l" command. This case is going
to show me some information about the bucket.
It's--what it is, is a listing of the ACL
on the bucket and this long string is a canonical
ID that's for this users--saying that this
is the--the one user. So this is a private
bucket that one user has full control and
no one else has read access besides that user.
And if I--if I want to see everything that's
in the bucket itself, I can use a wildcard;
so, here, this is going to give me information
about all the different objects in the bucket,
the things I just uploaded. And you can see
the upload times and you can see the mime
types and also the ACLs. And again the ACLs
show that all of the objects I uploaded are
initially private in full control just to
meet the user that has is here, so. And one
other thing that's kind of handy to do either
if you're interested in knowing more to see
the underlying HTTP protocol that's being
used there--the rest of the protocol or sometimes
for debugging purpose, if you want to see
what's going on. If you add the "-d" option
and I'm just going to look at the short thing
because it's going to generate a lot of output.
I'm going to use "gsutil -d ls" on the bucket
and that actually will show you the HTTP headers
that the request, there is the GET request
and the headers that are being sent including
the authentication header and there's a response,
so that's kind of handy to do. So one of the
things I one to point out is this URI syntax
with the combination, the URI syntax and wildcarding
is actually not just convenient but also was
very practical--in a very practical sense
represents the comment we've been making several
times now, both David and I have made about
giving users the control to get their data
out anytime. So, in particular, say I have
a bunch of files and up inside the bucket
and I want to get the data out for whatever
reason it's as easy as saying "gsutil cp"
to the local directory and there I've done
it. I've just copied all my data back out
of the Cloud. And if I want, I could even
copy it all over to another provider. So it's
as easy as that.
Thank you. Okay, so now I've talked to you
about the command line tool and that tool
is useful for, if you're someone like me,
I actually like using command line tools better
than GUIs, but--it's, you know, a matter of
personal preference. It also can be useful
for scripting, so for example, if you have
a big site and you wanted to have a production
site and you have a bunch of contact you want
to make live, you could write a script that
would run GSUtil and copied it into a production
bucket and set up, make live bit, how ever
that works in your application. Next thing
I want to show you is about the library, one
level down from there, if you remember it's
the extended version of boto and what we did
was we extended it with a new class hierarchy
and I want to show you right now what that
is. So right here I have a very short script
called "demo.py" and for the three-line script.
And you can see first thing it does is it
imports a Storage URI method out of boto and
that's a little convenience method for instantiating
the Storage URI class. And that class hierarchy
is kind of the main thing that we've added
in addition to support from multiple credentials
in the boto config file. And what these little
script will do is instantiate a URI with a
given name, this happens to be a publicly
readable URI. Anyone of you could go run this
script and it will work because you have access
to this particular "shakespeare/rose.txt"
file. And then it just gets the contents out
of the string. Now, this is going to work
fine because it's a little short file, obviously,
if it was a terabyte file you probably won't
want to do this. But now I'll just going to
go ahead and run it form the Python interpreter,
and there it's just connected the Cloud, retrieve
this little short text file and printed it
out for you. So it's pretty easy to use and
there's lots of other interfaces of the URIs.
You can do things like iterate over buckets
and get back all of the objects in that bucket.
You can manipulate ACLs, there's a lot more
that I'm not showing you here. I just want
to give you an example of how easy it is to
use as a basic function just to use this library.
The other comment I want to make is that script
as it stands, you can basically drop inside
of an App Engine App to make it work. And
so I want to show you that. If we look back
at the slide show now here is a--essentially
complete App Engine App and you can see highlighted
in here are basically the lines I just had
and that script I ran for you. And it's basically
complete. I've left out some imports and I've
left out some exception handling that you'd
probably want to implement if you're implementing
a real application. But for the purposes of
this it's basically complete and all this
does is when a user request the webpage it
connects and retrieves that object from the
Cloud from Google storage paints it in as
a free formatted HTML page and renders it
to the user. And now I'm going show you--I've
actually uploaded this application. If you
noticed I'd given an App ID for those of you
who use Google App Engine. The App ID is "cloudreader-demo"
so I've uploaded it. This is running on actual
Google production servers is that--is that
App Engine App--oops, what just happened here?
Something didn't work. Oh, well that's how
you know it's real and it's not a fake demo.
Okay, so that's it. Thank you.
>> ERB: So as I mentioned earlier we're beginning
a preview period now. And during the preview
period you're use of the Google storage is
free. We are publishing some pricing information
about the pricing that we'll have after the
preview period. It's pretty simple model,
you pay for the data that you store, aggregated
month by month and you pay for each request
that you make, you pay for transfer bandwidth,
and these terms are--this price sheet is also
available on the websites. So it's--it will
be easy for you to refer to them. During the
period we're not offering any particular SLA,
we are taking the availability and reliability
to the service very seriously. But it's--but
we're not offering an SLA. We will be offering
an SLA in the near future. We'll also be offering
some additional support options beyond the
normal online forms, discussion groups and
so on. We'll be making Google Storage available
to premium Apps customers. Today, if you need
to use twin Google Apps account not on a premium
Apps Google account to sign up for Google
storage, we'll be dealing with that very soon.
I mentioned earlier that we're going to be
allowing you to specify sharing to groups
that's not in the service today but it will
be very soon. We're also working on resumable
uploads. You know, I uploaded an object just
the other day that was 98 gigabytes and I
want to leave myself a little bit of headroom
in my 100 gigabyte quota. But, you know, if
something--I said earlier things fail all
the time that's something--if the connection
had been dropped for some reason partly through
that upload that would have been very inconvenient
you have to start over, and if it's a much
bigger object even more inconvenient. So we're
going to make it possible to resume uploads.
And as I mentioned earlier we're deploying
our storage systems in multiple geographic
locations but all in the United States currently.
We'll be announcing additional regions in
the not to distant future. So how can you
get started with Google Storage? Well, you
can request an invitation. I will say we published
this and we got a lot more interest than we
expected. So our invitations servers had been
absolutely slammed. So my apologies if you
have trouble getting an invitation right away
but we're working on that, we're working to
fix that very quickly. That system is not
based on Google Storage. And be sure when
you fill in your request for an invitation
that you write--that you attended the I/O
session in the additional information section.
We're getting a large number of requests and
we want to make sure that you, people who
came to the session, are priority people for
getting your invitations. And then we'll send
an invitation in your email. And on the "bit.ly"
link there, by the way, that's "dbO" not zero
"B1f." So with that I think we're ready to
go to questions. I'm going to ask you, Mike,
to flip your machine over to the web links
for questions.
>> SCHWARTZ: Ah, okay.
>> ERB: So if you are going to ask your questions
here please come up and use one of the microphones.
So we can capture it for posterity. Okay.
>> What about CDN usage like Echo Myers stuff
like that?
>> ERB: We're not announcing any specific--any
particular CDN product. Google has a very--it
has a global presence with its network and
it has a--we take advantage of a wide range
of excellent Google technologies to deliver
high performance. Go ahead.
>> Hi. Thanks for the talk. I have a double
question actually. I saw you were using MD5
as the hash of the files, it's very easy actually
to generate collisions for MD5. So do you
actually use something else? Do you provide
any other hash function for retrieving your
fingerprints on the files?
>> ERB: No, we don't and the reason for that
is partly an interoperability issue. But I
was concerned about that too and looked into
that back when we started working on the project.
And what we're really using the MD5 hash for,
in this case, is not any kind of security
or authentication, it's really just kind of
a check some to make sure that an upload succeeded
or for you to make a request and say "If I--if
the version of the object that's in storage
is different from the one that I know about,
the one that I scrolled on MD5 hash away for
then I want to do something." So we don't
see any vulnerabilities that comes out of
the fact that collisions are in fact possible
in MD5.
>> Okay then, the second part of my question
is besides the rest full APIs that you presented
to you have an API that, for example to take
a hash of input and return the buckets and
the objects that actually have that content?
>> ERB: No we don't.
>> Is it something you're planning on doing?
>> ERB: We're interested in hearing what anybody
thinks would be valuable to do and so we'd
love to hear your suggestions. And, in fact,
on our website, there is a place where you
can go make suggestions. So we encourage everybody
who has ideas for features and functions they'd
like to see in the service to let us know
about them. We'll be paying good attention
to that.
>> SCHWARTZ: And also just to add to that.
We have a Sandbox, we'd love to have people
come talk to us one-on-one, talk about ideas
like that; it's over on the Google code, on
the flip.
>> Okay. Thanks.
>> ERB: So I think we should probably take
one of the online questions. So the first
question "What advantages does Google storage
have over Amazons S3? Well, I'm not really
in much of a position to comment on Amazons
products and services. We hope that you will
take a good look at the different Cloud storage
providers that are available to you and make
a determination about what makes sense for
you to use. Let's see--oh, it's right here,
isn't it? It'll be easier. Will controls over
location of data be provided for Google storage?
Distribution is great for speed but there
are legislative issues internationally. When
I mentioned earlier that we will be announcing
additional regions, yes, we will give you
control over use of those regions. So why
don't we take one here?
>> Can you comment on the comparison of this
in the Blob store functionality?
>> ERB: Oh, sure. Yes, the App Engine's Blob
store API is optimized for use in App Engine
and the references are designed to be stored
in the App Engine data store and when you
pull a reference out of the App Engine data
store you can immediately use that to--the
App Engine can immediately use that to de-reference
the Blob. It's kind of a different service,
you know, they offer objects up to two gigabytes
which is ample for many, many applications.
We offer, you know, this service offers much
larger, much larger objects as a possibility.
So, you know, they're similar in that they're
both Blob stored services but there are a
lot of differences in--we think in kind of
those scenarios that they fit in to.
>> Is there support or have you thought about
support for, sort of like Medikey's such 4.4,
4.3 or that nil key so that you could potentially
just run static sites directly off of GS?
>> ERB: That's an interesting question. We
haven't really thought abut that and that
definitely falls into the category of things
we'd love to talk to you about. Go ahead.
>> I have two thoughts. First is, do we have
versioned objects? So can I version an object?
>> ERB: No. We' don't currently have versioned
objects.
>> And second, I appreciate the Constantine
model but it clearly influences latency. Can
you bit go in--explain a bit how it works?
>> ERB: Sure. The--I won't go any great details
because this kind of gets into some things
that we worked very hard on for a very long
time. But the--I think if you experiment with
Google storage, you'll find that you get really
good latency on read and write operations.
I encourage you to go try it out and find
out for yourself. Go ahead.
>> Do you need to pay for bandwidth from App
Engine to Google storage?
>> ERB: Let's see. That's an interesting question.
I'm actually going to hand that over to our
product manager. So I'd like to invite Jessie
to come on up and join us on the stage because
I don't know the answer. Do we have a...?
Oh, yes. We have a microphone. It should be
on.
>> FRIEDMAN: Okay. Actually the answer is
really simple because we're actually still
evaluating what's the best way to do it. We
will collect data during the preview period
and figure out what's the best way forward.
>> ERB: Thanks, Jessie. So let's see, we have
another question online here. Google Content
it is very useful in App Engine App but my
App blobs you know, as user log in using Google
account for Twitter and Facebook, is there
any guide about how to implement it on App
Engine? I'm not sure I'm actually completely
following this question but I think the--I
think what Mike demonstrated earlier about
using Google storage from App Engine might
be a good guideline for getting started. Go
ahead.
>> When I make a request, does it support
progressive download or screening? Can I stream
from the services?
>> ERB: Can you stream from the--well, we
don't really have explicit support for, you
know, rate controlled streaming. We do have
range get operations, we can get partial objects
and I've played with that a bit and I've had--I
have in fact, you know, uploaded media files
and played them out on a [INDISTINCT]. So
if you're interested in support for streaming
operations, I'd like to hear more about what
your needs are.
>> All right.
>> Could you comment on recursion from the
GS Util tool for sub-directories and stuff?
>> SCHWARTZ; Sorry I can't here the question.
>> ERB: Recursing. Recursing on any of those
sub-directories.
>> Recursive copies on sub-directories with
the GS Util tool, is that possible?
>> SCHWARTZ: Yes. So, basically, decided to
make the interface simpler than normal Unix.
Command line tools you actually explicitly
say "-r" and we felt--a pretty common case
if you name a directory is you just want that
directory. So you--if you want to copy an
entire directory, you just name the directory
or you can use wildcards within the directory
and similarly on the bucket site.
>> Would that were the same? Because the buckets
are flat structured?
>> SCHWARTZ: Oh, so there are cases, that's
a good question, there are cases where the
object names that are inside of buckets will
not be compatible with a file name. So let
me give you an example, suppose you have a
bucket with--supposed you have a bucket that
had an object called "X" and another object
called "x/y." If you just did a copy of all
of the objects in the bucket into the local
file system, it would first create that object
"x" as a file and then it would go to try
to create the object "x/y" and it would fail
because there is a directory--there's a file
where a directory needs to go, namely "x."
And the tool actually catches some cases like
that. It tries to do something to prevent
errors or detect things like that and warn
you about it. But that's just the consequence
of the fact that the hierarchical and flat
name spaces are sort of not always compatible.
>> Thank you.
>> ERB: I want to cover a few of the questions
online all at once. So you can see we have
questions about do we plan to offer encryption?
Is there a timeline for replication? Are we
thinking about creating any open storage specs?
And we're not really going to talk about specifics
for features that I didn't already mention
and we don't have a timeline that we're prepared
to announce for the things that we did talk
about. Go ahead.
>> So there is a storage like service today
in Google? I think I paid for it and I have
like a DGB assigned. Is this going to somehow
integrate with all of the Google docs and
mail and all of those things and can I actually
pull files from docs using this sapient, put
files for docs using this sapient?
>> ERB: I'm not a present--there are really
separate services in it. The docs list API
is really designed for one set of used cases
and Google storage is kind of designed for
a different set of used cases. But we're very
interested in hearing about interest in that
kind of connections. It's certainly not infeasible
but it's not something that we've done yet.
>> Are there any rate limits on uploading
and downloading?
>> ERB: Let's see. No, there aren't any rate
limits on uploading and downloading that we've
imposed, I mean, there are certainly limits
that--that the infrastructure between your
machine and my machine will impose on us.
But that's about it.
>> Just a question about authentication. So
having beaten my head up AllSub and AllAuthor,
are we now getting another third option to
play with? Whether we like it or not?
>> ERB: For--it serves the question are we
going to be adding a lot of support?
>> Yes, basically.
>> ERB: Well, it some--again that something
that we're interested in hearing about the
level of interest that people have. So...
>> And then as a follow on to that, if it
was a server to server based platform, so
clients are uploading things in the web, how
productive then we want them to put it into
this back end [INDISTINCT] replication earlier
or the good stuff. Would best practice be
to register a specific Google account and
basically just run on that basis though it's
only for that server environment?
>> ERB: I think that sounds like a very good
way to do it, yes, that's probably what I
would do in that situation.
>> What about support or the plans support
for custom metadata on buckets or objects?
>> ERB: Oh yes, there is support for a limited
amount of custom metadata. This--again this
is kind of--if you're familiar with other
rest full APIs, it's a similar kind of thing
were you can supply HTP headers that say "x-goog-meta-"
your tag and then the value and you can store
a couple of kilobytes of metadata with an
object there. I think we're about out of time.
But thank you very much for your attention.